happy Valentine's Day everybody let me
begin if I could with a quick tip a
little bit of advice for all the guys
out there you know I've been married for
seven years I have three kids so I think
I'm kind of an expert at this point I'm
certainly in the position where I can
dole out advice I believe so
if you are if you haven't gotten a gift
yet for your wife or your girlfriend and
you're kind of panicking because it's
the last minute well don't worry about
it I'm here to help you out okay now
first a warning you're gonna hear a lot
of people claim that a good gift for
your wife on Valentine's Day might be
like a handwritten love note and maybe a
gift card to a spa or something but no
no no see that's not let me tell you
women enjoy practical gifts the first
thing when they get a gift the first
thing I think it is what can I do with
this how can I use it so you can't go
wrong with a nice pack of new sponges
let's say or a really high-class
high-end laundry detergent and I'm
talking about I'm not talking about $15
laundry detergent I'm saying you could
even go out and splurge spend 25 bucks
on the really nice laundry detergents
the kind of lingerie it's urgent that
you that you get for special occasions
like Valentine's Day anniversaries and
so forth of course a mop is always a
good choice but be creative be
thoughtful about it maybe think like
what is your wife's favorite color well
get a mop in that color another idea is
a gift bag or a kind of a gift basket
with all different kinds of cleaning
supplies you got your Windex and your
you know your different kinds of bleach
and so on Clorox and all that kind of
stuff what I'm doing just just and you
can steal my idea if you want I'm that's
fine I am I got my wife a very nice
beautiful dustpan and I'm Rotem note on
the dustpan with suggestions about what
areas of the house you could clean so
anyway it's gonna be great she's gonna
swoon I'm sure over it so that's my
suggestion it is it is if you follow
this suggestion it is guaranteed to get
a reaction a big one a big reaction that
that I can be sure of
all right I want to so let me mention
this quickly at the top here Mitch
McConnell Mitch McConnell speaking of
Valentine's Day the other ladies love
Mitch McConnell Mitch McConnell doesn't
get enough credit I think he especially
from conservatives and he he certainly
has earned his share of criticism over
the years I'm not going to deny that but
he also is someone who knows how to play
the game and I think you should get a
little bit of credit for that sometimes
he makes a move on the chess board that
we just have to stop and appreciate so
yesterday McConnell announced that the
green New Deal resolution proposed by
Alexander okay Gio Cortes that he's
going to put that resolution up for a
vote in the Senate now obviously the
resolution has absolutely no chance of
passing through the Senate but the idea
here clearly is to take this insane
incoherent barely legible jumbled mess
and force Democrats especially Democrats
who are running for president force them
to officially put their name on it and
vote for it so that it can be used
against them on the campaign trail and
now during debates and everything
they're going to be forced they're going
to have to answer for the green New Deal
and explain all the different facets of
it like hey by the way how are we going
to get rid of all the farting cows how
are we going to replace every building
in America all of that stuff so it's a
it's a great tactic on McConnell's part
on the other hand what the Democrats
could do is is they could vote against
it but then they're gonna anger their
base so it's a lose-lose situation for
them which is why it's a brilliant
strategy on McConnell's part it's also
why senator and Edna senator Ed Markey I
almost really just accidentally called
him Edie malarkey Edie Markey who is one
of the guys who wrote the green New Deal
he said this yesterday he was very upset
he said don't let Mitch McConnell fool
you this is nothing but an attempt to
sabotage the movement we are building he
wants to silence your voice so
Republicans don't have to explain why
there are climate change deniers
McConnell wants this to be the end but
this is just the beginning
did you get that McConnell is sabotaging
them by putting their resolution up for
a vote see usually it goes the other way
around if if the Republicans won't vote
on something that the Democrats want
then they'll say that it's sabotage
they're being blocked they're being you
know they're being interfere it's
interference or whatever obstructionist
so usually it's obstruct its
obstructionist if you don't vote for it
it's sabotage if you do but the thing is
Markey is of course right in a way
McConnell is trying to sabotage them and
as well he should the green New Deal
should be sabotage but he's doing it
simply by voting on it so he's just
voting for the proposal and that's how
you sabotage it so what does that tell
you it tells you that the proposal is
insane the proposal is so insane that
the best way to defeat it and punish
anyone who supports it is simply to vote
on it and you find this a lot with
Democrats you find this complaint quite
a bit especially recently these days
they'll they'll accuse Republicans of or
conservatives of sabotage or deception
or dishonesty just for taking them
seriously and in quoting them verbatim
of course think of a Trump at a he was
at the rally a few days ago and at the
rally he said that Ralph Northam wanted
to make it legal to execute babies after
they're born and liberals freaked out
they said he's lying this is outrageous
fake news blah blah blah but no he was
actually quoting Ralph North Northam
almost verbatim but liberals support
such heinous policies and such terrible
vile ideas that all you need to do is
quote them and it will sound like you're
making it up
so yeah if you didn't know any better
and you heard that line from from Trump
where he's talking about Ralph Northam
executing babies if you didn't know any
better and yet you hadn't
pay attention and you heard that line
you would say what's crazy must he's
making that up
that's a terrible thing to make up but
no that is actually what Northam said he
didn't use the word execute but that's
obviously what he was implying
so the liberal strategy is to say
heinous things and then accuse anyone
who quotes them of lying another example
the undercover Planned Parenthood videos
from a few years ago they were the
Planned Parenthood was caught on tape
trying to sell the body parts of aborted
babies which again if you didn't know
any better and you hadn't been following
it and you heard some conservative
saying that Planned Parenthood is
selling baby parts you might just kind
of viscerally react to that and say no
there's no way isn't it that's crazy
you're dilute your hallucinating is
there's no way they were doing it but
but yes that is what they were doing
they're on tape all you have to do is go
watch the video there's hours and hours
dozens of hours of videotape that you
can watch where they talk about this but
the left side it's it's a dot it's
doctor they doctored the footage no they
didn't it's not doctored in fact Planned
Parenthood did their own investigation
of the footage and even they said in
their own report which you can go google
it and find it online the Planned
Parenthood did or did their own report
their own investigation of these
undercover videos and even they said
they admitted that the footage is not
doctored that's according to them
because it wasn't this is just what they
said this is this is what these Planned
Parenthood employees were caught on tape
saying it's as simple as that so that
tells you everything you need to know
about leftist policies that that in
simply repeating them verbatim it sounds
like you're lying alright so here's
something else speaking of a vile
horrible
atrocious things you know in our in our
increasingly decaying culture there is a
popular sort of event that I'm sure
you've heard of by now the event is
called a drag queen story hour okay and
I was just reading about another one of
these that was held in or it's going to
be held in Greenville South Carolina
originally it was cancelled because of
protests from the community people the
community said we don't want this at our
library but now it's back on and caving
to PC pressure the library in Greenville
South Carolina they're going to hold the
event anyway like so many other
libraries across the country have and as
I said there have been events like this
across the country and it is exactly
what it sounds like a drag queen comes
in and reads stories to children dressed
in drag which means that parents actual
parents actual alleged parents choose to
bring their kids to the library bring
their kids to library so they a drag
queen can read them books let me
actually say to their kids hey let's get
in the car and drive to the library
because a man in a dress wants to read
you a story why do you need a drag queen
to read your kid a book why does the man
need to dress like a woman before he
reads the book how does this enhance the
book reading experience at all well who
knows I do know actually the idea of
course is indoctrination that's that's
the point to shove this stuff into the
faces of kids early and often in life so
that they never think it's weird or
strange when I was a kid we inherently
recognized as kids that it is strange it
is unhealthy it is not good for a man to
go parading around like a woman when I
was in when I was a kid when I was in
fourth or fifth grade
if a guy dressed as a woman had come to
read us a book we would have all just
laughed at it we would have said this is
we would have seen it as this really
weird funny bizarre strange thing which
it is that is the appropriate reaction
with a child sees a man dressed like a
drag queen the appropriate reaction is
is laughter a kind of disturbed confused
laughter that's that's that's how you
should react but what the left is trying
to do with with the cooperation of many
parents is to brainwash these kids early
in life so that they don't have that
natural reaction and they see perversity
and they see things that are debauched
and deranged and they think well that's
perfectly normal but I want to focus on
another aspect of this issue in fact let
me put a I'm going to put a picture up
on screen for those of you watching on
youtube or on Facebook this is an image
from a drag queen story hour in Palm
Springs and this isn't even the worst
one that I could find but here's here's
a here's a drag queen reading of a story
to the kids so you can see he looks like
some kind of r-rated dr. Seuss character
completely gratuitous ridiculous
outlandish disturbing and there are much
creepier ones than that this is a let's
look at another one this is from a drag
queen story hour at the Boston Public
Library so look at this it is literally
like something out of a horror film
grotesque disturbing I mean that is it
looks like something that you would see
it looks like maybe maybe if you were
you know on LSD or something like that
it's it's something you would see so and
not only is that is then we'll talk
about this in a second this is my point
not only is it that last one offensive
but also to to Catholics as well because
this is someone dressed up like some
sort of caricature of a nun and there is
a whole by the way there's a whole group
of drag queens that do a lot of these
story hours and they're called I'm
trying to remember what they're called
they're called the the Sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence and their whole
thing is to make fun of nuns to dress up
like these kind of acid Trippi
caricatures of sexualized nuns and to go
around reading reading stories here's my
question
leaving aside the trauma that's being
inflicted on children with this nonsense
not that we can really leave that aside
but focusing on something else for a
moment my question is how is it that
drag queens have escaped the black faced
backlash I mean all of these people
upset about blackface about people
dressing as a black face especially
Democrats in Virginia dressing in
blackface well we're told that that's
offensive and demeaning and and and and
all of that okay fine
but isn't dressing and drag isn't that
just a female blackface drag shows are
essentially female minstrel shows men
dressing as exaggerated sexualized
caricatures of women female traits are
parody parodied satirized to the point
of absurdity okay this is not you look
at that you look at that guy dressed
like a dr. Seuss character that's not a
tribute to women drag queens are women
turned into cartoons and you'll notice
always sexualized that guy's in like a
little miniskirt I mean it's always it's
there's always a sexual element to it
always so tell me this ladies I'll throw
it to you you could tell me for yourself
do you feel like your femininity like
your womanhood is celebrated by a drag
queen or is it more so appropriated and
aped and mocked
I could tell you this if it were a woman
dressed like some dumb absurd character
of a stupid frat boy or something I
would look at that and say wow she
totally gets me
I feel so celebrated that's a tribute to
manhood I would say okay she's obviously
making fun of me I wouldn't cry about it
but it would be clear that this is
insulting not uplifting every everything
we could say about blackface it all
applies to the to the drag queen thing
too and even if I were to agree which I
certainly don't that the drag that
dressing and drag is a tribute to women
but even if I were that excuse doesn't
fly for white people dressing like black
people Ralph Ralph Northam says that he
dressed as Michael Jackson did the
moonwalk and this was meant to be a
tribute to my using he was a fan of
Michael Jackson he wasn't trying to
making fun of him but we're told that
look even if you do it as a tribute even
if you try to I mean megyn kelly got
fired from her job for even suggesting
that it may be okay to darken your face
in an effort to to pay tribute to a
famous black person so we're told no
that's you can't you can't do tribute or
not know it's offensive it's degrading
it's imitating mocking it's just no okay
fine like I understand that well it's
the same exact thing with this that even
if it isn't even if it is supposed to be
a tribute that's not how you pay tribute
to someone by dressing in an exaggerated
sexualized ridiculous costume and
parading around on stage readings or
reading stories the children that's not
a tribute but of course it's not even
supposed to be a tribute anyway that's
not even we all know that's not the idea
here and what about
appropriation I brought up this point
plenty of times in the past but everyone
is worried about appropriation people
are you know appropriating cultures well
that's what this womanhood is really
actually being appropriated by this drag
queen stuff by transgenderism you have
womanhood being appropriated stolen
taken you know taken over by by men in a
way that is that is again degrading and
demeaning I just I think it's about time
that the the LGBT community stops
getting an exemption from all this stuff
it seems like they're exempt from all
this all you know the appropriation
black-faced all that stuff they're
exempt they can do what they want and no
one's allowed to be offended no one's
allowed to complain and especially women
aren't allowed to complain because there
are there are there are plenty of women
who would agree with everything that I'm
saying and there are even feminists
there even liberal feminists not very
many who are willing to say it out loud
but there are there are some there's a
substantial number of liberal feminists
who are just trying to draw the line in
the sand and say no enough of this is
crazy enough of this you know you're a
man you're not a woman
you can't pretend to be one there's a
difference between us and you're not the
same I'm not gonna treat you like the
same and what happens to those feminists
when they say that there was a liberal
feminists got kicked off a Twitter for
simply saying that men are men and
they're not women I just think it's time
we start holding everyone to the same
standard speaking of which last thing
before we get to some of your emails
trying to pull it up give me a second
here
so I got someone sent me this a few days
ago I've been wanting to talk about it
and just other subjects have gotten in
the way so let me mention it now
someone from Dickinson College sent me a
editorial if we can call it that that
was in the Dickens Sounion college
student newspaper and there's been
there's been an article about this on
The Daily wire now but the the title of
the article is should white boys still
be allowed to talk and the article in
this student newspaper is just one long
attack against all white boys suggesting
that they shouldn't even be allowed to
speak anymore let me let me read a
little bit others to you
written by Lita Fisher or later Fisher
and that's very pronounced name when you
ask a question at a lecture is it
secretly just your opinion ending with
the phrase do you agree if so your name
is something like Jake or Chad or Alex
and you were taught that your voice is
the most important in every room
somewhere along your academic journey
you decided your search for intellectual
validation was more important than the
actual exchange of misinformation now
how do you expect to actually learn
anything American society tells men but
especially white men that their opinions
have merit and that their voice is
valuable but after four years of
listening to white boys in college I am
not so convinced in my time at Dickinson
I have listened to probably hundreds of
white boys talk it feels incessant from
classes and lectures to the news and
politics there is an endless line of
white boys wanting to share their
opinions on the state of feminism in
America whether the LGBTQ GQ population
finally has enough rights the merits of
capitalism etc the list of what white
boys think they're qualified to talk
about is endless something very few of
them seem to understand is that they're
ill informed uncritical opinions do not
constitute truth in fact most of their
opinions aren't even original and then
so I won't read the whole thing so on
and so forth you get the idea
though and it goes on like that for four
or five paragraphs concluding with the
proposal that white boys should not be
allowed to talk anymore now I mean this
is I get that it's just a student
newspaper free speech and everything
like that as well although she obviously
doesn't believe in free speech she
thinks that she's complained she said
well white boys have been raised with
this idea that their opinions are
worthwhile
well yeah I mean we're supposed to raise
everybody with that idea that they're
allowed to express their opinions so she
doesn't believe they should have first
memorized but speaking of you worthless
stupid ugly opinions that have no value
and do not need to be expressed and
should not be given a platform well
there you go this is just some a woman
having a a racist hissy fit spending
four or five paragraphs complaining
about all white boys and just insulting
them and saying none of their opinions
are worthwhile none of them should be
able to talk and the newspaper said the
student newspaper said yeah let's let's
run that no again see we need to stop
making exemptions for people this is
just sexist racist idiocy it has no
value it has no worth it is totally
stupid there is nothing redeeming about
it whatsoever we don't have to we don't
we don't have to even stop to consider
this person's opinion or perspective on
this subject for even a second
and obviously if if if a white if a
white boy had written an article like
that targeted at women targeted at black
people targeted at any other group there
would be protests in the street there
would be outrage across the country the
I mean they'd be shutting the school
down over it but of course the article
never would have been run in the first
place because people because the editor
of that newspaper would have looked at
it and said no this is just racist
stupid garbage why would I put this in
the paper well yes exactly
alright let's read a couple of your
emails you can email the show at Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from
Mike he says I really enjoyed your
explanation on tax refunds and how
deceptive it is in the way that it's
structured by the IRS what is your
position on abolishing the IRS I've
heard from several conservative slash
libertarians including Ted Cruz during
the 2016 election saying they're in
favor of this but I am unclear how
exactly it would work presumably if you
did abolish the IRS it would have to be
replaced with something else in order to
collect revenue and hold those
accountable attempting to evade taxes I
hope you can explain this in a way I can
understand better Mike yeah I mean
personally if they're gonna abolish the
IRS you're not gonna hear any complaints
for me whatsoever this of course will
never happen but in a fantasy world
where it did happen I think most people
who favor getting rid of the IRS would
prefer to replace it with a consumption
tax with something like the Fair Tax the
Fair Tax is the idea behind the Fair Tax
is let's get rid of all the income tax
let's get rid of all the payroll taxes
thus we don't need the IRS anymore and
then we replace all of that revenue with
a national sales tax essentially and I
read a book on the fair tax proposal
years ago I don't know if it's been
updated since then but when I from what
I remember the idea was to replace those
taxes with I think was like a 25 percent
national sales tax on not every kind I
think like things like groceries will be
exempt but on on various kinds of items
now the way the proposal was was was
written the idea is to replace the
income tax so this isn't even like
cutting you know cutting the
government's revenue at all it's like
looking at how much the government makes
with income tax and how can we replace
all of that well it would mean a 25-30
percent sales tax I would I would take
that over the income tax I would take
pretty much anything over the income tax
I think the idea of it we're so used to
it now
we kind of take it for granted but the
idea of your income itself being
directly taxed I think is tyrannical
it's the kind of thing we only accept it
because we're all used to it and it's
always been this way but when you really
stop to think about it for a minute why
should the government have a right to
just automatically take whatever money
you make
especially in what's supposed to be a
free country so even though 25 30
percent sales tax is extremely steep and
I think you could cut it down to like I
don't know ten or fifteen percent or
less and the government can make do with
less money because that I think that
should be part of the point here but
either way at least with a consumption
tax then you are in some ways
controlling and deciding where you spend
your taxes how much tax you you pay in a
way by you can control that by
controlling what you buy so that's the I
think that's the basic idea for most
people that want to abolish the IRS this
is from well there's no name provided
says hello Matt I was listening to you
ramble yesterday about getting rid of
the withholding system I often suspect
you have no idea what you're babbling
about
and now those suspicions are confirmed
wait they were just now confirmed you've
been listening to me all this time and
you just now realized I have no idea
what I'm talking about
without withholding the government would
have to actively collect taxes most
people wouldn't pay there would have to
be a whole elaborate mechanism put in
place for collecting from people the
whole system would collapse and the
country along with it under the weight
of this system it's a terrible idea one
of many from you first of all thank you
so much for your support second you're
being dramatic of course how do you know
that most people wouldn't pay if there
was no withholding system where are you
getting that from do you have some sort
of study that you conducted over the
last 12 hours and anyway even if that
were true how would that precipitate the
end of civilization as we know it are
you really so subjugated are you really
so submissive
as to think that life as we know it
would end if the government had trouble
collecting income taxes dear Lord man
you should be embarrassed I'm
embarrassed for you do you think you
think the country would collapse if they
had trouble collecting the income tax
how do you think we got by without an
income tax which we did for many decades
and which many governments have have
figured out a way to do over thousands
of years government's have figured out a
way to to to get by without a
withholding system how do you think they
did it look the government brings in
about three and a half trillion dollars
a year in revenue okay
three and a half trillion now so that it
has to subsist on a measly three and a
half trillion to put that in perspective
there is only around five trillion
dollars of physical money that exists in
the world now obviously when we talk
about the government bringing in 3 1/2
trillion
we're not talking about physical money
it's not like they've got you know we're
mailing them bags of money or something
for the income tax but I'm just trying
to put it in perspective so their
revenue is technically three and a half
trillion and there only exists five
trillion dollars worth of physical money
in the world meaning the government
every year collects almost as much money
as exists in the world and half of that
is the income tax so even if the
government couldn't collect any income
tax from anyone they would still have
two trillion dollars to work with every
year your dear telling me that if the
government only had two trillion dollars
every year the the whole world would
collapse the civilization the country
would be over you're telling me the
government couldn't possibly figure out
a way to make do on two trillion a year
but of course they still would be able
to collect it would just take some
firt and it ought to take effort yes if
you didn't have a withholding system the
government would actually have to
physically go out and collect the taxes
just like governments did for thousands
of years of human civilization up until
the 1940s or 50s whenever the
withholding system began and that's how
it should be it shouldn't be so easy
that they can just dip right into your
page I could say I'll take that thank
you and just put it in their pocket
that's not how it should be yeah it's
easier but that's not think about it the
way it stands right now okay the
government gets gets a hold of your
paycheck before you do they get it first
and then they give you whatever the
leftover is do you think that's the way
it really should work in a free country
do you think the founding fathers who
were vaulted you know who are so upset
over a tax on tea that they overthrew
their government do you think they would
because they find that acceptable now I
know that there was more to it than the
tax on tea but the tax on tea was oh it
was a big part of it and taxes and taxes
in general is a big part of it for them
do you think they would you think they'd
be fine with that with a system where
the government could just go right into
your paycheck bypass you completely and
take whatever they want it's it is a
it's a shame all right from Joel he says
hi Matt in my US history class my
teacher says walls don't work he says
the 38th parallel separating North and
South Korea is one of his examples
saying that people still find a way
across it oh it's really so easy well
yeah maybe your history teachers should
go and try to cross the go ahead history
teacher go try to cross the wall down
there in those in the in in South Korea
and see how it works out for you if it's
really so easy just to just waltz across
it
give it a try and his other example uses
as the Berlin Wall also saying it did
war
and that people still got around under
and over it he's obviously referring
that the southern border wall wouldn't
work I wanted to ask him why would they
have needed to take down the Berlin
Berlin wall if it didn't work and
wouldn't a wall at least discourage a
majority of people from trying to get
across the border thanks for defending
Christian morals and values and real
masculinity by having a real beard
you're welcome love the show Joel I
think you have exactly the right idea
and I would encourage you to say that to
your teacher
the next time he launches into his
stupid little rant about walls showing I
mean it's sad that he's a history
teacher and apparently doesn't
understand much about the way the world
works or about history I would encourage
you to absolutely challenge him and
bring that up so oh is that is that true
mr. Smith so the Berlin Wall was totally
ineffectual didn't do anything so so
they've so why they take it down but why
not just keep it up then
now you notice something else though for
his examples of walls he's using
negative examine a reason why he uses
the Berlin wall and the wall separating
North and South Korea okay because
that's the Association he wants in your
mind for walls and he's also your
teacher here is setting up a clearly
unattainable standard for what works
he's basically claiming that unless a
wall stops everyone from crossing all
the time then it doesn't work well then
ask him this does he think that the
locked door on his house could prevent
anyone and everyone from entering he's
heard of burglary right people burglars
are able to bypass locked doors all the
time yet yet he still has a door doesn't
he and he still locks it why is that I
would ask him that question well why do
you if it doesn't do anything why do you
why do you shut your door tonight why do
you even have a door you know why
just put a big you know a big blanket or
something down or you know just have a
big curtain or your doorway is but you
know you you you actually have a door
and you'd lock it knowing that it's not
100% effective but you do it anyway why
is that oh it's because it's better than
nothing
right well exactly let's see I've got
some other I had some other great
questions I can't get Tuesday because
I'm running out of time but I will get
to those tomorrow I had I had some
emails about ectopic pregnancies and a
couple about aliens so those are that
but you know that though that's gonna
take more time to get into so I'll just
end with this from Kyle he says I just
farted in my car while listening to your
show it stank very badly I said without
thinking now there's some toxic
masculinity very good Cal poetic
insightful and I deeply thank you for
sharing and thank you for watching
everybody we'll talk tomorrow
Godspeed